les attentats aux états unis on vous en
a énormément parlé c'est bien normal
mais ce que vous savez peut-être moins
c'est qu'en france la vie de certaines
personnes a considérablement changé
depuis les événements du 11 septembre
t'aurais pas un petit exemple j'ai pas
un petit exemple j'ai un grand exemple
tu veux dire je vous explique nous avons
rencontré un enfant de 12 ans qui habite
en france hamelech tu peux venir au ceb
mais là c'était à côté de rennes en
ille-et-vilaine vineyard et pourquoi
elle est compliquée ça vieillit et
comment il s'appelle au fait je viens de
faire son devoir dire non mais comment
il s'appelle je ne peux pas 28 à peine
bonjour je m'appelle bout d'un moment
vous avez vous moquez moi nous nous
moquer de toi mais pourquoi comment tu
t'appelles voilée comme vous êtes sympas
je vais vous dire comment je m'appelle
regarder et ben voila je m'appelle nous
sommes mal comme oussama ben laden qui a
détruit les deux tours jumelles de new
york paul abadie donc oussama ça doit
pas être facile tous les jours se
portait le même prénom qu'un terroriste
international nom qui se moquent aux
cookies semaines démontrent les génisses
et madeleine comme aux saveurs et où on
voit là une mention c'est pas très sympa
j'ai un message à faire passer à tous
ceux qui se moquent des oussama ou
compris moi ça va parce qu'on s'appelle
oussama qu'on est tout un terroriste
comme nous vous avez les yeux marrons
comme ben laden à vous n'êtes pas des
terroristes
bah alors fait part il a une barbe c'est
pas un terroriste comme oussama ben
laden
alors arrêtez de vous moquer de nous ne
faites pas d' amalgame ne fait pas de
quoi d'un mâle gamme ou non mais c'est
qu'ils utilisent des mots compliqués
oussama c'est quoi ça un amalgame
un mélange d'éléments qui ne s'accorde
pas nécessairement vous n'avez pas très
bien compris je vais vous expliquer un
amalgame c'est un mélange d'aidé aux
enfants pourront tomber tous dans le
même sac
c'est ça on mélange tout on sait nous
confrontons voilà ah ouais d'accord
c'est plus clair comme ça mais
heureusement il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ne font pas d' amalgame et qui savent
bien que tous les housses hama où que
tous les musulmans ne sont pas des
terroristes
tiens les amis d'oussama par exemple ou
bien compris ça a lieu après tout ça
plaît ou samassa n'empêche pas d'être un
garçon comme les autres
pourquoi tu t'appelles où ça va les
parents ou appeler comme ça parce que tu
sais c'était le fils adoptif de nommer
c'est le prophéte arables vous dit rien
pourquoi ça vous seulement alors le
message est clair vous l'avez tous
compris il ne faut pas tout mélanger
bien sûr tous les oussama ne sont pas
des terroristes et beaucoup de musulmans
qu'ils soient français américains ou
d'un tout autre pays sont contre ben
laden leur religion c'est l'islam et
c'est une religion très tolérante à la
base
alors s'il vous plaît ne confondons pas